this whole movie seems like what he's
what it's dealing with from a character
psychological standpoint is temptation
[Music]
what is going on there reject nation
thanks so much for clicking on this
video if you could take a batarang to
that like button that'd be very much
appreciated we are going to watch
ourselves i think four new tv spots for
the batman that all supposedly include
new footage i just dropped them into
final cut hit export let's see what's in
store um i i really i can't i really
can't wait for this movie i've been
reading like so many articles on this
like from what barbara passage has been
talking about what calling ferals are
talking about i'm so excited for this
film like it or not it's written now
what are we looking for
more symbols
jesus's next victim is bruce wayne
it can be cruel poetic or
it's
blind
it's your violence you may find
the answer's justice
nipple chills
that was a great one
will feels good doesn't it
see you again
what do you live in a cave
you have no idea daddy does he do thirty
only peter's more
you're really not as smart as i thought
you were
this is about a gig
there's a match
[Music]
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
ah the rage
i'd be so surprised that this movie is
not good
i'd just be so surprised
[Music]
that's the new nerd footage there batman
3d pg-13 only beaters march fourth okay
i think it's a five egg
yeah
it's got a nice ring
you got a lot of cats everything about
strays
with this latest it's all about the
wings
goddamn
are you okay
i've been trying to
gross
away
who are you under there what are you
hoping maybe we're not so different
after all
a new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
if we don't stand up nowhere
you guys are held with the wedding
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's on your life
don't worry honey i got nine of them
yeah you do come on vengeance let's give
you some trouble
oh wow there's so much
experience
only
so much to gather god i'm having the
hardest i'd be i'm out i've reached a
point where i'd just be shocked if this
movie is less than great i'd be shocked
at that point you know i'm setting
myself up for disappointing
putting
like looking at what the film making of
this the contrast the colors the focus
lens that's just so beautiful to behold
thematically you know everything that
they're doing here like i love all the
new looks that we got here of colin
farrell as penguin how he relishes in
that criminal performance he said that
the makeup took like four hours a day to
put together eventually they got it down
to two and it wow
that that already alone just from the
marketing like that that makeup deserves
an oscar nomination how many of us did
not realize that was colin farrell from
the first trip
most of most of us were like oh that's
colin farrell i had no idea that that
was colin farrell knowing like what
robert pattinson has talked about
recently specifically in regards to the
portrayal of bruce wayne of him like
dealing with killing of how there's a
part of him that really does want to
actually kill there's a part of him that
probably does get some type of pleasure
in this like everything we're seeing
here with exploring that darker side and
i think what they're doing with catwoman
is brilliant because it seems like
especially from the marketing here in
the when you look at these clips put
together they have an enemy here who is
the riddler who they have to take down
who is terrorizing the city looks like
everything the anarchy he can provide is
just so diabolical and massive i'm sure
bruce is just tempted to kill this guy
but also wants to learn the secrets that
he knows but then you got a character
like catwoman who is willing to be more
of a criminal and willing to be a little
bit more dangerous and have some fun
with the darkness where it seems like
with bruce that it's kind of an
addiction for him like he doesn't take
pride or joy or have fun with the
darkness that this is a torture for him
that he has to let out whereas he's got
someone like catwoman who's like come on
man your vengeance let's go have some
fun you know this whole movie seems like
what he's what it's dealing with from a
character psychological standpoint is
temptation that's the main thing that
i'm getting from like watching these tv
spots just slap together and i feel like
that temptation could be very well uh
embodied in catwoman like yeah somebody
who i get the sense from all of these
images and all these clips that we've
seen is going to rub off on and
influence bruce's journey here and i
love that yeah like you have that
teetering balance of it seems like this
is really testing the side of bruce that
does have that murderer in him and that
vengeance inside of him and i think that
this you know really zeros in on the
tangibility of that you know
battle for the soul like as much as
there's always like a battle for the
soul of gotham bruce wayne is always
super tied up into that this feels like
the most
personal unraveling that for bruce as an
overall character and watching the
tension even just from these like i'm
like you i'm like i can't imagine a
scenario in which this movie isn't super
gripping and compelling because every
little bit of footage just engrosses you
and pulls you in and makes you want to
dissect it that much further and seeing
these new clips and images of the
riddler got me that much more excited
because i love that they've been doing
all these ciphers and things like every
trailer every poster has a new thing you
can crack and decode i love the presents
that they've drawn out and we've heard
some of the justice riddle already but
just his presence and the sinister
equality that he has there's something
about the riddler that i feel like will
really perfectly both push batman
towards that murderousness and even you
know you can tell yeah he probably would
want to like murder the riddler for all
the you know personal attacks that he's
taking on him but at the same time even
in these little glimpses cells that like
maybe i should listen to what this guy
has to say and unravel what the truth is
it feels just so scopic and huge that's
the essence of a batman movie what i'm
trying to really gather from all this
though is the connectivity with penguin
and we know carmine falcone is supposed
to be in this by john turturro knowing
that it's like the trailers do such a
good job on gripping on the central
parts of bruce wayne batman secrets of
the wayne family seeing the darkness
behind their riddler and catwoman yet i
i
i'm still having a hard time seeing like
what is the why behind the importance of
featuring penguin in this movie
specifically one thing i've been
thinking about is like some people are
like are they showing us too much i'm
like this movie's almost three hours
long and i still feel like i got so many
questions about how all this is going to
play out there's so many details i just
don't know once again got a shot at
michael giaccino's score here because
every time i hear like just a little bit
of a new rendition or whatever omits
that like horror unnerving vibe
throughout it just like crawls under
your skin knowing that he's putting out
there publicly that even gordon is
putting the pieces together too that
he's going after bruce wayne this really
feels like an identity crisis movie
and um i'm loving it and i like every
time i see more i'm just like i don't
know a way this movie will not be
amazing it's so hard for me to imagine
it to not be amazing and i know as an
audience member you don't want to get to
that point with the film but god damn it
i'm i'm like way over the line on that
already and uh that's where i'm at just
gotta be honest but guys what do you
think about these spots leave your leave
all your emotions down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button we
will catch you all soon
you